JESSE WATTERS AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
THE KENTUCKY HIGH SCHOOL WHO
STUDENTS ARE AT THE CENTER OF A
VIDEO CONTROVERSY IS CLOSED
TODAY DUE TO SAFETY CONCERNS.
LOCAL AUTHORITIES ARE
INVESTIGATING THREATS MADE
AGAINST SOME OF THE COVINGTON
CATHOLIC HIGH STUDENTS AFTER
VIDEO SHOW AN ENCOUNTER WITH A
NATIVE AMERICAN MAN IN
WASHINGTON.
A CHAPERONE WHO WAS ON THE TRIP
SAYS STUDENTS WERE TARGETED FOR
WEARING MAGA HATS AND DESCRIBED
WHAT HAPPENED.
>> I THINK THAT WAS ONE OF THE
REASONS THEY WERE TARGETED, AND
I THINK THEY WERE ALSO TARGETED
FOR WHAT THEY STOOD FOR, WHICH
IS CHRISTIANITY.
THE RIGHT FOR LIFE.
WE WERE STANDING THERE AND WE
LOOKED IN ALL OF A SUDDEN, THEY
TURNED THEIR ATTENTION TO OUR
GROUP AND THEY WERE SCREAMING
HORRIBLE, HORRIBLE THINGS THAT I
WILL NOT REPEAT TO OUR CHILDREN,
TWO CHILDREN.
NOT ADULTS.
THEY WERE SCREAMING THEM AT
CHILDREN.
>> Dana: TWO COVINGTON
STUDENTS DESCRIBING SOME OF THE
APPARENT THREATS.
>> THERE HAVE BEEN MANY THREATS
AGAINST OUR LIVES, AGAINST OUR
PARENTS.
SOME OF THESE SETS INCLUDE THAT
WE SHOULD ALL BE LOCKED IN THE
SCHOOL AND IT SHOULD BE BURNED
TO THE GROUND.
THE SCHOOL BEING BOMBED.
SCHOOL SHOOTING THREATS.
IT'S REALLY SCARY.
>> Dana: NATHAN PHILLIPS, THE
NATIVE AMERICAN ACTIVIST, SAYING
THAT HE IS WILLING TO MEET WITH
THE STUDENTS.
WE WILL SEE IF THAT HAPPENS.
JESSE, I WANT TO TAKE A LISTEN
TO AN EXCHANGE ON "THE VIEW"
TODAY.
>> IS IT THAT WE JUST INSTANTLY
SAY THAT'S WHAT IT IS BASED ON
WHAT WE SEE IN THE MOMENT?
AND THEN HAVE TO WALK STUFF BACK
WHEN WE ARE WRONG.
WHY DO WE KEEP MAKING THE SAME
MISTAKE?
>> BECAUSE WE ARE DESPERATE TO
GET TRUMP OUT OF OFFICE.
I THINKS THAT'S THE REASON FOR
THE PRESS JUMPS THE GUN BECAUSE
WE HAVE SO MUCH CIRCUMSTANTIAL
EVIDENCE AGAINST THIS GUY THAT
WE BASICALLY ARE HOPING THAT
COHEN HAS THE GOODS AND WHAT
HAVE YOU.
IT'S WISHFUL THINKING.
>> Dana: THERE YOU HAVE IT.
>> Jesse: I HAVE ALWAYS SAID
THAT THAT SHOW IS FILLED WITH A
LOT OF WISDOM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: YOU MIGHT HAVE A BOOK
ONE DAY AND YOU MIGHT GET
INVITED.
SHE WAS SAYING WHAT WAS ON HER
MIND, THAT'S MAYBE WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> Jesse: I THINK THE MEDIA
TRIED TO CALVE IN ALL THESE
TEENAGERS AND IT HAS INSPIRED
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY BECAUSE
YOU SEE THE INJUSTICE AND YOU
TURN THESE KIDS INTO FOLK HEROES
BECAUSE THEY HAVE OF FACE
CRIME.
HE MADE A FACE AND HE STOOD
THERE AND DID WHAT ALL ADULTS
TELL YOUNG PEOPLE TO DO IN THE
MOMENT.
NOT THROW A PUNCH, NOT YELLOW.
NOT DO ANYTHING HE STOOD THERE
LIKE THIS AND THAT WAS THE
CRIME.
THIS IS A GREAT LESSON.
WHENEVER YOU SEE A STORY IN THE
MEDIA AND EVERYBODY STARTS TO
PYLON, STEP BACK AND THINK ABOUT
THE COVINGTON BOYS AND WAIT FOR
THE FACTS.
SOME PEOPLE ARE LEARNING THEIR
LESSONS AND SOME PEOPLE AREN'T.
SOME LEFT-WING PERSON WENT TO A
HIGH SCHOOL BASKETBALL PHOTO AND
THE GUYS WERE GOING WITH THIS
AND THEY SAID IT'S A WHITE POWER
SYMBOL.
NO, THAT MEANS SOMEONE JUST HIT
A THREE-POINTER.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT THE WATCH
IS BASKETBALL.
WE LEARN FROM PARKLAND.
CHILDREN ARE OFF LIMITS.
I THOUGHT THAT'S WHAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE LESSON.
NOW YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
THE HAT WAS OFFENSIVE.
THE SMIRK WAS OFFENSIVE.
THIS IS, FROM THE SAME PEOPLE
THAT WERE YELLING AND CHASING
PEOPLE AND THEIR FAMILIES OUT OF
RESTAURANTS.
IT DOESN'T REALLY EQUATE.
YOU MENTIONED THE INDIAN AT THE
TOP.
HE WAS NOT A VIETNAM VETERAN.
THAT CAME OUT IN THE YARD TIMES
AND AT CLARIFY.
HE SERVED DURING THE VIETNAM
ERA.
>> Dana: IT WAS
"THE WASHINGTON POST" I THINK
THEY DID THAT.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE ALL
CORRECTING THE STORY.
>> Dana: BECAUSE HE READ ALL
THESE PAPERS ALL DAY LONG.
DAVID BROOKS WROTE A PIECE TODAY
ABOUT HOW WE DO DESTROY LIVES
TODAY AND WHEN THE STORY FIRST
BROKE ON TWITTER, EVERYONE WAS
LIKE OH, OKAY, THEY MUST BE
RACIST FOR THE NEXT DAY, IT MUST
BE LIKE LIBERALS ARE ALL BAD
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE
RACIST.
ALL OF OUR BIASES COMING OUT ONE
STORY.
>> Greg: WHO IS DAVID BROOKS?
>> Dana: HE IS A COLUMNIST FOR
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
>> Greg: EVEN WITH THE PEOPLE,
THE NEW INFORMATION, THEY ARE
CLINGING TO THIS LIKE A LIFE
PRESERVER.
ACTOR HAS BEEN JIM CARREY, THIS
IS THE LATEST PAINTING AND WHICH
OBVIOUSLY HE'S DEMONIZING THESE
TEENAGERS.
I HAVE TO HAND IT TO HIM.
NOW HIS PICTURES ARE AS BAD AS
HIS PICTURES.
WHAT NOW YOU ARE HAVING IS
REALITY IS CRASHING DOWN.
THIS WAS A LEFT-WING FANTASY.
YOU HAVE THE PERFECT VILLAINS,
WEARING MAGA, WHITE KIDS.
CATHOLIC STUDENTS AT A PRO-LIFE
EVENT.
PERFECT LAWN ORDER SUSPECTS.
THEY JUST NEEDED TO HAVE SUPER
RICH PARENTS WHO WERE
ARCHITECTS.
THEN YOU HAD THE PERFECT VICTIM,
NATIVE AMERICAN VIETNAM VET WAS
ISOLATED.
WHAT HAPPENS WITH A STORY LIKE
THAT, IT'S TOO GOOD TO CHECK.
BETWEEN THIS STORY IN THE
BUZZFEED STORY, THE MEDIA IS IN
WORSE SHAPE THAN MY LIVER AFTER
SPRING BREAK.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU ARE GOING
TO COME BACK FROM THIS.
IT'S SO BAD.
CAN I MAKE ONE LAST POINT AND
THEN I WILL SHUT UP.
IT'S A LOT ABOUT THE NATURE OF
THE SOCIAL MEDIA.
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW TO USE
SOCIAL MEDIA YET.
THE DEATH THREATS FOR EXAMPLE
ARE BECAUSE THERE'S A LOW
BARRIER OF ENTRY FOR DEATH
THREATS.
IT USED TO BE IF YOU WANTED TO
MAKE A DEATH THREAT, YOU HAD TO
CALL, TAKE A RISK, THEY COULD
TRACE YOUR CALL.
NOW ANYBODY.
THREE AND EARN 50 MILLION, HOW
MANY MILLION?
ON THE INTERNET, AT LEAST 1% OF
THEM ARE PSYCHOPATHS.
THEY CAN MAKE DEATH THREATS.
WE DO NOT KNOW HOW TO DEAL WITH
THIS MASSIVE BEHEMOTH.
IT ALSO MAKES PEOPLE LESSER
VERSIONS OF THEMSELVES BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE EYE CONTACT.
WE CAN'T READ EACH OTHER.
I CAN DEMONIZE YOU AND YOU CAN
DEMONIZE ME AND I CAN SAY HEY, I
MADE A MISTAKE.
AND YOU CAN SAY THAT'S NOT GOOD
ENOUGH.
>> Dana: IF IT IS SOMETHING
THAT SUPPORTS WHATEVER YOUR
BIASES, MAKES YOU FEEL BETTER.
EVERYONE HATES SOCIAL MEDIA BUT
NO ONE IS GETTING OFF OF IT.
IS IT UP BECAUSE WE'RE AFRAID
WE'RE GOING TO MISS SOMETHING OR
WE ARE AFRAID WERE NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO POLICE THE OTHER SIDE
OR WE THINK IT'S GOOD FOR OUR
OWN -- IT'S WHERE WE BELONG NOW?
>> Jedediah: IT'S A LITTLE BIT
OF EVERYTHING.
WE ARE ADDICTED TO IT.
#DoNotDisturb.
IF WE ARE NOT THEY ARE AND
EVERYBODY ELSE WAS THERE, WE
FEEL LIKE WERE MISSING
SOMETHING.
A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO
DON'T HAVE A MICROPHONE, WE ARE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE A
MICROPHONE ON TELEVISION TO SAY
HOW WE FEEL.
MANY PEOPLE FEEL LIKE I DON'T
WORK IN TELEVISION.
THIS IS MY WAY TO GET MY OPINION
OUT.
EVERYONE KIND OF FEELS LIKE A TV
STAR OUT THERE.
THEY GET TO SEE THEIR PEACE AND
THEY GET RETWEETED AND THEY
GATED OUT THERE IN FRONT OF YOU
KNOW SOMEBODY WITH A BIG
MICROPHONE WILL PICK IT UP AND
NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY BECOME
FAMOUS.
IN THIS DEBATE, I HAVE TO SAY I
APPRECIATE THE JOY BEHARS OF THE
WORLD BECAUSE THEY ARE BLUNTLY
HONEST.
SHE'S WILLING TO SAY WHAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE AND MEDIA WON'T SAY
WHICH IS THAT THERE'S A MISSION
TO BRING DOWN PRESIDENT TRUMP AT
ALL COSTS AND THEY ARE WILLING
TO DO THAT WHETHER THE
INFORMATION IS TRUE OR NOT AND
THAT IF THEY SEE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PAINT SOMEBODY WITH A MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN HAT OR AT A
PRO-LIFE RALLY OR WHATEVER THE
CIRCUMSTANCE, THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PAINT THEM AS
BIGOTED OR RACIST OR WHATEVER TO
TIE THEM TO TRUMP, THEY'RE GOING
TO DO IT.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
NEED PEOPLE LIKE THAT BECAUSE
SOME OF THE PEOPLE IN MEDIA,
LIKE GREG SAID, THEY ARE
STICKING TO THEIR ARGUMENT THAT
THEY ARE NOT TELLING YOU WHY.
THEY ARE NOT BEING HONEST ABOUT
THIS IS A MISSION TO TAKE DOWN
THE PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE SAYING OH, NO, WE ARE
RIGHT FOR THESE KIDS REALLY ARE
RACIST AND THEY ARE FISHING FOR
SOMETHING THE PAST THAT MIGHT
INDICATE THAT.
YOU HAVE TO BE GRATEFUL FOR THE
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT THAT ARE
TELLING YOU EXACTLY WHY THEY ARE
DOING IT AND WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
YOU AND YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE THE
FACTS AND YOU KNOW WHAT YOU ARE
RALLYING AGAINST.
>> Dana: IT ALSO COMES TO HOW
WE GET OUR NEWS AND THE WAY THAT
NEWS OUTLETS SOMETIMES PAY THEIR
REPORTERS WHICH IS CLICKS, YOU
ARE MEASURED ON HOW MANY TIMES
THERE'S A WEBSITE CLICK TO YOUR
STORY, DOES IT CONTRIBUTE?
>> Juan: I IMAGINE IT DOES.
I THINK THIS IS A BIGGER STORY
ABOUT SOCIAL MEDIA.
I THINK WE ARE ALL GETTING
PLAYED BADLY BY THE STORY
BECAUSE THERE'S MORE VIDEO AND
MORE VIDEO, BUT WE ONLY SEE
PORTIONS OF THE VIDEO.
THERE'S A NEW VIDEO OUT THAT
SAYS THAT TWO YOUNG WOMAN
SAID --
>> Dana: WE HAVE THAT.
IT'S A VIDEO THAT THESE WOMEN
SAID THEY WERE BEING HARASSED BY
SOME OF THE STUDENTS BEFOREHAND,
AND WE HAVE THAT BLOCK?
>> [SHOUTING]
>> I'M SO TIRED ALREADY.
>> Juan: NOW THIS CASTS THE
KIDS IN A VERY NEGATIVE LIGHT AS
HAVING HARASSED PEOPLE
PREVIOUSLY.
WITH THEIR MAGA HATS AND THE
LANGUAGE.
WHEN I SAY WE ARE BEING PLAYED
BADLY, DANA, I'M TALKING ABOUT
THAT TWITTER HAD TO SUSPEND AN
ACCOUNT.
THEY PUBLISHED HIGHLY POLARIZED
POLITICAL CONTENT, LEFT AND
RIGHT, INTENDED TO DIVIDE
PEOPLE.
SUPPOSEDLY BASED IN CALIFORNIA,
TURNS OUT BASED IN BRAZIL AND
THEY DON'T EXACTLY KNOW WHO'S
PUTTING IT OUT.
THEY ARE TWEETING 130 TIMES A
DAY.
40,000 FOLLOWERS.
THE VIDEO WHICH THEY PUSHED
AGGRESSIVELY WAS THEN BOUGHT
INTO BY MAINSTREAM MEDIA IN THIS
COUNTRY AND AGAIN, THE INITIAL
INTERPRETATION PROVED TO BE
WRONG.
AT THAT POINT, THEY HAD
2.5 MILLION PEOPLE LOOKING AT
THIS VIDEO AND LEAPING TO SOME
KIND OF CONCLUSION.
I WILL SAY NATHAN PHILLIPS, THE
NATIVE AMERICAN ELDER, SAID THE
KID HAS NEVER APOLOGIZED TO HIM.
HE FELT STARED DOWN AND HE FELT
THREATENED BY THE KID AND HE
THOUGHT THAT WITH THE BLACK
ISRAELITES WERE UP TO WAS
OFFENSIVE BUT HE THOUGHT THE
KIDS AND THE ISRAELITES WERE
ABOUT TO CLASH AND HE WAS TRYING
TO BE A PEACEMAKER.
SO NOW YOU GET PEOPLE ON EITHER
SIDE, ESPECIALLY THE RIGHT AND
THE FACT THAT HEY, A LOT OF
THESE INITIAL INTERPRETATION WAS
WRONG.
NOW THE KIDS ARE TO BE
PROTECTED.
THEY ARE ANGELS.
I THINK BOY, WE AS AMERICANS, WE
GET FRAGMENTED, DIVIDED
INTENTIONALLY BY THESE PEOPLE
FOR SOME REASON AND WE PLAY INTO
IT.
WE ARE SUCH DUMMIES.
>> Dana: MAYBE PEOPLE HAVE
LEARNED A LESSON BUT IMAGINE
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.